hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to the fifth and final lot of
their tip that I have for you guys and
this one's gonna be about development so
while you're actually doing a lot of
their how you should essentially be
developing your game I guess let's get
started first of all follow your plan
okay the very first tip I gave to you
guys what was planning okay and that's
you can see the video there go ahead
check it out it's loving the tips
planning that's the title of the video
that video talks about how you should
approach the theme that you receive when
you when love and death starts and how
you should essentially break down what
kind of game you're gonna make and plan
it okay that's very important okay
because when you're developing your game
you want to be following that plan
otherwise if you have no plan you're
kind of screwed okay
so try and stick to your plan okay
remember that new ideas means less time
okay you will be running out of time if
you continually have new ideas I know
it's tempting but you have that planning
period to think of pretty much
everything and like it's fine to take
like I'd say up to an hour or so just to
plan exactly what you want to do again
in in the planning stage drew do a
brainstorm whatever just plan what you
want to do and then of course make sure
that you stick to that plan during
development because um because like it's
you know while new ideas aren't
necessarily a bad thing okay in fact
they can many times save the game just
remember just be cautious with new ideas
don't just decide to do whatever comes
to your head just because um just
because someone said so or I guess just
just because you decided that it's a
good idea okay don't try and do that
what you want to do is just you know if
you really think that that new idea is
gonna be very very beneficial to the
game and in fact it'll be more
beneficial than you finishing we can't
you have even though you're running out
of time then yeah try that new idea but
otherwise just but just because without
sort of thing do not suddenly change the
genre of your game okay if you're if you
wake up if you go to bed at the end of
the first day you wake up tomorrow
there's like 26 hours left until the
competition ends and you're like you
know what this games good but I'm in a
2d kind of platformer yeah I think like
a 3d first-person shooter would be
better for this genre nah dude you've
got 26 hours left okay
just make sure that you follow your plan
don't do drastic changes never do
drastic changes like changing genre all
right Kim it right you've chosen
something you've chosen a game to make
make that game commit to it please okay
features so what features you should add
and follow that so you got to manage
your time wisely with with features the
features is kind of like the I guess
it's kind of like what was the other one
planning okay it's kind of like the plan
like with features right so um you've
got a plan and you want to implement
these features but you have to manage
your time wisely okay if you need input
implement something like AI give
yourself a time limit for that
okay give yourself let's just say AI AI
has to be done in two hours okay and
then stick to that because um if you
kind of just forget about time and you
don't really follow your plan of course
you're gonna kind of run out of time
eventually that's going to be a problem
so remember a new feature equal equals
more time this is kind of like this is
kind of like the previous one where you
want to add add more and more and get
new ideas okay new features equals more
time okay as in it'll take more time
okay
whenever you decide that you want to add
a new level or a new menu system or hang
on let's add a new gameplay mechanic
that's gonna take you time to implement
and a good rule to follow here is that
if you estimate a feature to take two
hours to implement it'll probably take
four so make sure you have that time
okay if i realistically want to add a
new gameplay mechanic and i'm gonna be
like i don't know that probably take me
about an hour and a half make sure you
have room for three hours because it'll
probably end up taking that long okay
honestly because especially in the late
kind of game stuff when you start make
it when you start trying to add new
features and for some reason you like i
don't know this game isn't satisfying to
me i want to have something new to it
other other features might break because
of that and because you're in such a
kind of limited i guess time capacity
you might not realize at the time of
writing those previous features or the
engine that it wouldn't allow for this
kind of thing and thus it can break a
game and anyway just make sure that you
have enough time if you really want to
add new features don't break again guess
that leads me to my next point
do not break your game
be careful with that because I know that
you can spend three hours implementing a
feature and then finally when you're
just about to launch it that's it like
you realize oh no the way that I'm
handling tiles like it's never gonna
work with this pathfinding algorithm or
something just be careful with that okay
because breaking your game is very very
real very possible and it will make you
cry and that's a bad thing okay do not
add additional features before your game
is stable when you plan out the original
like I guess I guess plan or the
original I guess like timeline and
facialist for your game the original
gameplay that you plan out for your game
implement that first don't suddenly add
new features just cuz they came to your
head make the game stable make the game
playable first and then if you have
loads of time if you're literally done
with your entry and you have 20 hours
left
yeah go ahead add new features please
problem it will hopefully make the game
better because well I guess if you
adding new features and making worse
it's a bad thing but do not add new
features before you games done okay
seriously do those features you
originally planned and and then move on
to the new features if you have a lot of
time left organize yourself this is a
big one and I know a lot of you guys
probably gonna be complaining because
there's an S and I'm a Zed and organized
that's how you spell it in Australia so
yeah alright so folder and hierarchy
structure bro seriously have your
folders structured have all your files
and your hierarchy I mean stuff like
classes packages in Java folders in C++
whatever have that stuff very well
structured okay keep yourself organized
not only will it help you it will also
motivate you clean have a clean desk
even that's actually important right
when you're developing you want to have
a clean desk you want to have you don't
have dirt everywhere you don't want to
have a cluttered desk that sucks I'm
gonna be honest right now I am much much
much more efficient in my development if
I have a clean desk just because I feel
cool I feel good about myself I feel
good about what I'm developing so that's
really really really really really
important file names and variable names
okay name it what you need to name it
okay if you don't know constructive name
for it or if the name is too long say
it's like 15 characters long
it doesn't matter name it that okay you
want to be able to understand your own
code I would not go as far as to say
comment your code
I honestly almost never do this and
unless I'm working in a team or I need
to I don't know submit the project a
university or essentially other people
are gonna read it if you're just
developing it by yourself comments you
could help you at multiple times but
don't don't feel the need to like to
Javadoc your entire and your native
health if all of them there
I wouldn't say go as far as comments but
I definitely would say make sure your
variable names are constructive don't
name stuff a B whatever just leads me on
to my next spot don't even think about
obfuscating on the go why do people do
this I see I see a lot of people in both
University and in freaking I on
especially on YouTube naming their
classes a a a a b a c dude why you opt
for skating on the go seriously why you
do who does this honestly can someone
give me a good reason for this don't
even think about telling me security is
a good reason for that because that's
why obfuscators exists after you after
you freaking zip your you jaw archive
your your your application what who
obfuscates on the go don't even think
about doing this okay it will slow you
down so much and it will in any kind of
large-scale project you'll just screw
yourself over do not opt first get and
in fact you have to release the source
code anyway full of them dare if you're
doing the Comper not the channel don't
think you have to for the jam but for
the compote you need to release the
source code anyway and I don't think
people are gonna appreciate it if it's
obfuscated so do not even think about
doing that please set time goals and
work to finish them okay what I mean by
that is let's just say it's 12 p.m.
right now I need to have this level this
level system this entities this entity
ant level system done by 3:00 p.m. okay
do stuff like that and then as you say
oh it's past 3:00 p.m. I haven't even
frickin started yeah well I haven't
finished it yet you can see how you're
going for time okay and you can actually
I I guess you can have like a triage
system right you can you can order
things from more important to less
important in terms of do in terms of
implementing those features and I guess
development of them okay so make sure
that you do set time goals and you work
to finish them
that's what let him dare essentially
will be it'll be a structure of goals
and time allocated to it's like a
project what I love about love and dare
is you're literally your own games you
here and you have 48 hours to make a
game from start from inception to
release to marketing to finish which is
which is really really cool
but you make sure you you actually
organize yourself and do that stuff food
and sleep people always forget about
this part of the food part dude you're
gonna get hungry and unless you have
people who are kind enough to bring you
food and and stuff like that I'll make
you food or whatever you're gonna have
to get that food yourself somehow now
cooking is fun I love to cook for myself
but during lot I'm there that's probably
not gonna be an option because um I
can't waste an hour or so cooking that's
not good
so what I would recommend you do is you
either make something the night before
and put it in the fridge and heat it up
or whatever the next day or you order
something like pizza or I don't know
going out isn't great because it takes
time unless you happen to live you know
ten meters away from a restaurant also
you have to obviously wait for them to
prepare your food puff from the journey
there and back so I would honestly
recommend that you are that you have the
food in your house somehow or get it
delivered like pizza that way you can
keep developing until you hear the door
knock so yes all your phone rang okay
have fun right I've settled this stuff
but have fun stress isn't great okay
you're not doing loving bear to stress
you don't love them better make an
awesome game and have a good time okay
the point of LA dumb dare is to make an
awesome game chill out have fun and test
yourself that's what it's all about
don't stress no one's gonna no one's
gonna do anything if you don't make a
game your honor man if you feel games
crap no one's gonna say anything like
that probably will but you don't have to
submit it or whatever or even if you do
just go ahead like no one's gonna really
judge you there's no like winner for
this competition as in there's no like
there's no like cash prize or anything
there's it's just one of those just
laid-back chill composite competitions
where the goal is just to basically get
2,000 people to make a game that's what
it's all about right let them dare it
should be about fun in fact probably is
so if you're not having fun doing
there you need to either rethink game
development as a hobby or as a career
but more importantly you need to get
your priorities straight like why are
you doing a lot I'm there because if
you're not having fun doing it there's a
problem somewhere okay
I understand that a lot of people might
be stressed but I mean III could say the
perspective is you know when I'm
live-streaming there's usually about 250
people watching me make a game and
obviously I have this channel here with
like twenty one point eight thousand
subscribers so if I don't make a game
and let them dare I could see the
picture of oh sure no I can't even
finish a game blah blah but honestly
like I don't even feel stressed when I'm
developing in front of 250 people so if
you guys if you guys are feeling
stressed while you're doing a lot um
dare just relax okay it's about fun
that's what I really want to stress
about it a stress but anyway I want to
stress that it's about fun okay it's not
about stress and it's not a university
project okay no one's gonna mark you for
this it's should be about fun so please
please have fun with it
you will learn that's one of the great
things about long term whatever you make
you will learn something new guaranteed
I do every time I do let them dare I
benefit myself immensely okay that's
part of the reason why I love doing it
I'm like dude I can't wait for this
weekend I'm gonna learn so much about
programming and game development that's
exactly what it should be like you will
make something that is the other other
or the awesome thing you will have
something that you can be like hey Mike
you're my best friend
play this game I made I made it fully
and it's complete and you can play it
it's playable you will make that and
that's awesome okay that is so precious
that is your prize for lot I'm dead a
lot of people ask me is there any prize
for a lot of their allies their waters
what does the winner get is there like a
top-10 prize your prize is your creation
okay that and that is the best prize you
could ever have honestly from a game
development competition the thing that
you make it forces you to make something
and you make it and you have it it is
yours you've you get a product you will
have fun okay it's making a game making
games is fun it's fun you will have fun
touring love them des although you don't
stress out so just make sure you keep
that in mind
relax okay just sit back keep your chair
back don't feel compelled to stream okay
I'll go on to the next page and I'll
talk a bit about that but a lot of
people I know that a lot of people are
streaming and streaming slows you down a
lot I'm gonna be honest with you guys I
think if I wasn't live-streaming I'd
just kick back on my sofa with my laptop
and I'd I'd make again and I have a lot
of fun not that I'm not having fun when
I'm streaming but the point is just
relax this is about you this competition
this isn't about people watching you
this is about you okay this is you
making a game okay just that's what it's
about so relax kick back on the sofa
with a laptop develop a game and just
have fun with it man this is this is
what it's all about again so yeah
anything else yeah
time lapse it this is cool there's a
program called chrono lapse just go
search on Google for it it's called
chrono lapse so chrono elapsed one word
it's a time lapse in software right so
what it will do is you'll set a time
interval let's just say five seconds and
every five seconds it will take take a
screenshot of your monitor or your
monitors if you've got more than one and
and essentially the part about that and
all app put it as like a PNG is that you
can grab all those images and use them
as frames play it back at like 24 30
frames per second whatever and you what
you get is a very very very fast version
of those 48 hours that you spend on
however many hours you spend developing
the game which is really really cool
cause you can see yourself making the
game in about 5 minutes or 10 minutes ok
that entire game you made from scratch
in 10 minutes and that's really really
cool and then you can upload it to
YouTube and leave me to it because I
want to watch it it sounded like I said
I want watch it I do want to watch it
that's what I meant I want to watch it
so make sure y'all put it on YouTube oh
yeah stream it stream it okay if if you
happen to have a nice setup and you've
got a pretty fast computer and you think
it won't slow you down go ahead and
stream love them there okay it's fun
you'll get people watching you hopefully
and and I I guess the benefit of that
will be that um well you know it's gonna
be fun to interact with people on that
kind of level and it's part of the
reason I do it last trimming is a lot of
fun as long
you don't stress out about it okay if
you're stressing out about it all
there's 20 people watching me I
what if I screw up oh I did such a
rookie error there don't worry about
that okay if you are worried about that
don't strain me because you're just
gonna end up having a worse and much
more pressure time release the early
versions that's always fun I like to pop
up an earlier version like an alpha or a
beta of my game maybe like 5-10 hours in
and get people just to play it and then
they can like be like oh it's fun or
it's [ __ ] or it's cool or it works at
least and that's always fun and that
that's more for the community than for
me I'm not gonna take tips from you guys
being like oh dude like it it'd be more
fun if you added this if you had a DES
blah blah it's more about you guys
getting to see the game as it evolves
and that's really fun for you guys post
onto lovin bear slash compo if you sign
in and you have pretty sure you have to
create an account there if you want to
submit oh yeah you would but make sure
you are you posted back basically post
like blog post that that homepage is
made up of blog posts from I guess users
so um go ahead and just son it's like a
wordpress site you just site you just
grind and count and and you just post
stuff so basically you can be like oh
here's I'm two hours in here's my
screenshot that's what it looks like I
mean you can get some feedback from that
hopefully as well as I you kind of get
to see a journal of your game at the end
which is a very very cool so mesh make
sure you interact with the community
that's part of the best part and
continue your awesome idea after lot of
their finishes or LVS ounce of love and
they're obviously when let them dare is
complete okay hopefully that theme and
the amount of development you've done
over the last 48 hours that will trigger
some kind of motivation for odd this is
actually a really cool game I'm gonna
keep making this after let them dare and
then go ahead and keep making it okay
that's what it's all about so um and
then maybe you can even release it on
something like iPhone or whatever and
and and charge some money for it and
there you go be good a bit of a you've
got a bit of a commercial indie game
that you've just released which is
awesome so that's what lot um there is
it's also all that okay that's pretty
much it I hope you guys enjoyed these
five tip videos the playlist to them
will be down below in case you missed
any of them and 20 become for such the
channel was of course my Twitter
accounts oh my said channel Twitter
channel Twitter compost as Joe knows my
Twitter and
I'll be obviously posting about a lot of
their there so you can follow me on that
if you don't want to miss me streaming
which leads me on to twitter up there
before such the Cherno that's where i'm
going to be streaming the entire lot um
dere 28 competition so go ahead and
follow me there and follow me on twitter
because twitches and greater than
mousing live streams but twitter i'll be
tweeting out one a live stream on
twitter so make sure you follow that if
you don't want to miss anything but par
from that guys i hope to see you guys
from so tomorrow's when it starts it
starts in about from what I'm recording
this like 10 hours so I'll see you guys
sorry not 10 hours what am i doing 22
hours so we'll see you guys I'll see you
guys in Londonderry later guys bye